[Music]
on this Friday night Millions baking and
unbearable heat the dangers of cooling
off at some Canadian beaches it's
definitely disappointing and the worries
about a worsening drought
sea water becoming hot tubs the dire
consequences for Florida's coral reefs
and the mission for conservationists
new evidence against a former Supreme
Court Judge accused of misconduct that's
it the police body cam video just
released and a Ukrainian fencer makes a
point Cruise the defiant act that nearly
derailed her chances to compete but one
hurt worldwide support
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight nipu gotcha good
evening and thanks for joining us we are
hearing new warnings the planet might be
at the point of no return from rampant
wildfires to record-breaking heat waves
this summer the effects of climate
change are being felt across Canada
today there were multiple heat warnings
in parts of Atlanta Canada and up north
in the Yukon and Northwest Territories
but the largest area under a heat
warning is one of the most densely
populated parts of the country more than
7 million people live in the region
spanning from the southernmost corner of
Ontario to just north of the greater
Toronto area temperatures there are
scorching Environment Canada says
several spots saw the humidex reach 40
degrees in our top story tonight Eric
Sorensen looks at the toll these soaring
temperatures are taking
a dip in the lake just what the doctor
ordered in a heat wave except Health
officials in Toronto have declared four
public beaches in Toronto unsafe for
swimming while some take to the water
anyway others are staying out and
keeping their kids out too they like
splashing around in it so it's
definitely disappointing when the equal
eye levels are too high for them to go
in with E coli health issues typically
arise first from rainfall heavy rains
over the country's biggest city cause
runoff into the lake and E coli levels
to spike and you can see a rise of very
predictable rise in uh E coli and other
bacterial counts in the lake Toronto
Beach advisories have happened many
Summers over the years from high E coli
levels but the problem could get worse
in the future with big rainfalls and
longer hotter Summers just another
consequence of climate change Toronto
Health officials are out every day
Testing Research has shown that E coli
bacteria thrive in warmer water and
climate modeling predicts hotter weather
going forward heat waves will become
more intense and they will last longer
and more frequent as we head into the
future you know we have to be concerned
about the the changes that may come
because there are impacts if there's
more frequent uh large storms and more
runoff or uh higher temperatures yeah
unfortunately there you know there's a
possibility that we'll see more frequent
closures because of bacterial accounts
it has been a hot and brutal summer
across the country the worst year for
wildfires in Canadian history in British
Columbia drought conditions are getting
worse and the driest time of year the
month of August is still to come in
Vancouver new restrictions will kick in
this Friday prohibiting lawn watering
and other water uses for the first time
in eight years we are calling on
everyone in BC to reduce their water
usage
every drop counts and the cautionary
tale out of North Vancouver earlier this
month a man discarded a cigarette near a
backyard pool and six hours later the
fire broke out the flames and Embers
spread quickly a reminder that while a
warming climate is creating more risks
for wildfires humans are still
responsible for many of the fires that
break out in this country Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
extreme weather is also hitting the U.S
leaving millions in potentially
dangerous conditions according to that
country's National Weather Service 60
percent of the U.S population is under
heat advisories or flood warnings that's
roughly 200 million people forecasters
expect heat records in several major
cities to be smashed this weekend with
places like New York and Washington
already feeling hotter than 35 degrees
due to humidity yesterday in Phoenix
where people have been burned from
sitting on pavement the city marked 28
straight days of temperatures hitting at
least 43 degrees Celsius that's 10 days
longer than the previous record set in
1974.
later on global national the race to
save endangered Coral off Florida's
Coast how climate change has sped up
coral bleaching and the fears the
devastation could spread around the
world
for now though there are signs the
Canadian economy May finally be slowing
down preliminary data shows gross
domestic products shrank in June the
first contraction this year it follows a
point three percent bump in May matching
Economist expectations Mackenzie gray
looks at what's happening and what it
all means for your bottom line
United will never be defeated public
sector strikes in Raging wildfires still
couldn't stop the Canadian economy from
continuing to post-modest growth the
fact that the economy means to Cherno
decent growth in the second quarter
especially given the challenges it was
dealing with is is a little bit of a win
manufacturing numbers combined with
resilient consumer spending saw the
largest growth in the Canadian economy
since January but there were some
negatives oil and gas took a major hit
down 2.1 percent because of the
wildfires in Alberta but even then that
slowdown is likely temporary the decline
was not as significant as we've seen in
previous instances notably the pandemic
the Fort McMurray fire
despite High interest rates increased
immigration help housing prices continue
to Roar forward sales were up 7.6
percent in May but new construction was
down 1.8 percent the wrong combination
for those looking to see prices drop but
High interest rates will likely soon
have an impact from this point forward
with overnight Ray as high as five
percent it's really hard to see a you
know just the strength in housing
activity being sustained over the year
but continued growth might be coming to
an end statscan is predicting a 0.2
percent contraction in June which calls
into question the bank of Canada's
projected soft Landing that's where
inflation gets to two percent and the
Canadian economy doesn't go into a
recession any private sector economists
believe a minor recession is likely
later this year leading to a different
kind of Landing I think what I would say
for Canada is we're looking at a
hard-ish landing here not not really a
full on recession but as you say a bumpy
ride that turbulence is likely to lead
Tiff Macklin to hit pause on rate hikes
the Bank of Canada will not raise rates
any higher it is done enough to start to
bring inflation down the expected June
GDP drop represents the first major
issue for Justin Trudeau's economically
focused cabinet as they hope to avoid a
recession or at least navigate through
it nithu Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mackenzie A Member of Parliament is
calling on Ottawa to Halt funding for
the Calgary Stampede at issue is a
lawsuit alleging the organization
allowed a performing arts school staff
member to sexually abuse boys a partial
settlement has been reached in 2018
Philip harima was sentenced to 10 years
in prison for sexual offenses against
six teens who were members of the young
Canadians after previously denying any
wrongdoing the Calgary Stampede accepted
liability and negligence this week for
being aware of the abuse saying they
should have known much sooner Calgary
Skyview MP George chahal says the
Stampede has lost people's trust adding
in a statement that funding should only
be reconsidered when the victims feel
that genuine accountability and
Reconciliation have occurred
a clearer picture is emerging of an
alcohol-fueled night that cost a
Canadian Supreme Court Justice his job
Global News has obtained new body cam
footage of a confrontation from last
winter involving former judge Russell
Brown he resigned last June after a
complaint to the Canadian judicial
Council but details remain hidden from
the public tariya isri reports on the
push for more transparency here at home
does the Supreme Court Justice he's
literally Supreme Court of Canada you
can't see the former Supreme Court judge
in the video but Witnesses say you can
hear him
oh man he's serenading in a tuxedo the
incoherent voice allegedly belongs to
Russell Brown
heard in New Body cam video released to
Global News by Arizona's Paradise Valley
Police Department
a group of friends met the ex-judge from
Alberta at a hotel bar last January
Brown was in town to speak at illegal
Gala they allege the former Justice was
drunk and started harassing the women at
the table then tried following them up
to their room
sorry
someone complained to the Canadian
judicial Council and a few days later
Brown was placed on leave nothing was
made public just an Asterix on a case he
was supposed to hear confirming he did
not participate
the news eventually came out with U.S
authorities releasing body cam video
what you have here is the stark contrast
between the way matters are dealt with
in the United States and the way that
they're dealt with here when it comes to
the Judiciary and as you've seen in the
United States there's tremendous
transparency Brown has called the
allegations contradictory and inaccurate
but resigned last month one complaint is
one too many it should never happen
but that's reality it happens Brown
stepped down before the Canadian
judicial Council released a report into
his conduct it recommended a public
inquiry which now won't happen since he
resigned but the council is keeping its
findings secret I find that
extraordinary a report that was intended
to make a hearing public itself is being
kept in private prime minister Justin
Trudeau will now have to review
applications for Brown's replacement the
deadline to apply for the job closed one
week ago
Global News Ottawa
the legal trouble surrounding former U.S
president Donald Trump just keep on
growing he was hit with additional
charges late Thursday in a case linked
to his handling of sensitive documents
the U.S government alleges Trump an aid
and an I.T worker at his Florida estate
were actively plotting to tamper with
security cameras regichini reports
the abuse of power it's a it is
prosecutorial misconduct denial remains
Donald Trump's number one defense tactic
after the special counsel investigating
the mishandling of classified documents
filed a superseding indictment on
Thursday this is one of those crimes
where the cover-up is worse than the
crime the original indictment detailed
31 counts of willful retention of
classified material by the former
president hinting at one specific
document believed to be plans for an
attack on Iran Trump is now charged with
having that document along with new
obstruction charges that swept up a
Mar-A-Lago staffer with claims that
Trump directly LED efforts to delete
surveillance footage showing boxes being
moved Trump denies wrongdoing destroying
evidence in response to a grand jury
subpoena attempting to do so conspiring
to do so is more problematic than the
false statements or the Espionage Act
charges the new charges came as a
surprise as Trump's legal team focused
on the looming indictment in Washington
over his efforts to overturn the 2020
election poll numbers are through the
roof but they did this in order to get
me out
despite Trump's legal woes his Playbook
of criticizing the process and playing
the victim still seems to be working to
his Advantage being Leaps and Bounds
from his closest competition they know
him they're used to him they like his
positions and also they hate the media
so much that the media telling them that
Trump can't win is another incentive for
them to vote for Trump Trump's campaign
and Court calendars meanwhile are about
to feel the squeeze with five civil and
federal trial dates already scheduled
starting in October and that doesn't
include anything from the state of
Georgia where barricades now surround a
courthouse in Atlanta where Trump faces
the possibility of yet another
indictment into election interference
in Washington thanks Reggie a military
General has declared himself the new
leader of Niger after a coup that
toppled the president of the small West
African country
International
on state television General Abdul Rahman
Tiani called on International Partners
to cooperate with his new regime he also
again accused ousted president Muhammad
bazoom of poor governance and
deteriorating National Security bazoom a
key Ally of the West in Africa was
arrested by his own presidential guard
led by tne during Wednesday's
military-backed coup he's not formally
surrendered power international allies
have widely condemned the plot calling
for bazoom's immediate reinstatement
our country's Women's National Soccer
Team Nets a tentative deal with the
sports governing body but the athletes
are not celebrated we'll tell you why
coming up
police in Nova Scotia say the search for
a missing youth Following last weekend's
devastating flooding is expanding
authorities say they have exhaustively
covered the original search area and are
now searching in a neighboring field and
an extended stretch of a nearby River
yesterday police confirmed the
identities of the three bodies recovered
this week as 52-year-old Nicholas
Holland and six-year-old Natalie Harnish
and Colton Cisco
a man connected to an investigation into
the deaths of eight migrants in Quebec
has been found dead police say the body
of 30-year-old Casey Oaks was found in
the Saint Lawrence River earlier this
month he had been missing since March
Oaks boat was found near the bodies of
eight migrants in late March it's
believed the two families including two
young children were trying to cross into
the U.S illegally from Canada
the Canadian women's national team has
reached an interim agreement with Canada
Soccer to secure compensation for 2023.
the deal includes prize money from the
ongoing FIFA Women's World Cup and
ensures equal pay with the Men's
National Team there was little
celebration over today's announcement in
a statement the team says we have been
forced to choose between compensation
and the funding required to hold
necessary training camps and it says
this is not over the seventh ranked
Canadian women have been without a labor
deal since the end of 2021.
ahead why conservationists are removing
Coral in the hopes of rescuing Florida's
reefs
[Music]
typhoon dog Suri swept into Southern
China and Taiwan today unleashing
violent winds and heavy rain on millions
in the region gusser said to have
reached nearly 175 kilometers per hour
during the peak of the storm it was so
powerful at one point roof tiles were
seen flying off of a local Stadium State
media says more than 400 thousand people
had to be evacuated because of the storm
in the U.S scientists say climate change
is driving an ecological catastrophe off
the coast of Florida where ocean
temperatures are shattering records in
some places the water is as warm as a
hot tub leading to a mass bleaching of
coral reefs as Jackson prosco reports
the die-off is unprecedented and risks
spreading to oceans around the world
when researchers dove into the water off
the Florida Keys they were stunned by
what they saw once pristine coral reefs
are now ghost reefs everything is dead
you can feel the heat in the water and
you see you look down and you see just
white Coral skeleton it's heartbreaking
the water here is so unnaturally hot the
delicate corals can't survive ocean
temperatures have been above 32 degrees
Celsius for weeks Florida's Manatee Bay
hit a record 38.4 degrees that's the
same temperature as a hot tub so if the
coral animal begins to Die the reefs
erode the reefs break down there's no
more habitat left for these critical
organisms that we rely on as people
every day corals protect land from
hurricanes they provide a home to fish
and other marine life and now they're at
risk almost everywhere globally sea
surface temperatures seen here in red
have soared off the charts scientists
are stunned by how fast it's all
happening and by how hot the water is
when we realized all these temperatures
were Rising we actually thought
something might be broken with our model
it goes to show us how much excess heat
energy
um from climate change from global
warming
um how much of that excess heat the
oceans have been absorbing back in the
water there's now A desperate Race
Against Time
conservationists are trying to rescue
the most endangered corals nursing them
in tanks hoping to eventually replant
the reefs right now there are strains of
coral in our nurseries and there are
outplanted corals on reefs that would
not exist without our work
without Global action to address climate
change and bring down ocean temperatures
they admit they can only do so much
the trouble hidden below the surface is
a clear warning sign about the dangers
of our rapidly warming world
Jacksonville Global News Washington
[Music]
global national Canadian screen Award
winner for best national newscast
good sportsmanship is greatly valued in
any competition but what if your
competitor is from a nation that's
invading your own this week at the World
Championships a Ukrainian fencer who won
was disqualified all over a handshake
Mike Armstrong on the act of defiance
and the outcome
International Fencing Association was
warned this could happen Ukrainian team
competing at the World Championships
said its athletes wouldn't shake hands
with athletes From Russia with the two
countries at War I
Owen four-time world champion Olga
Harlan trounced her opponent Thursday
she extended her saber to tap blades
instead of a handshake that was what
fencers did during the pandemic her
opponent refused but it wasn't over and
a smirnova didn't leave she stayed on
the fencing pissed for more than 50
minutes smyrnova demanded Harlan be
disqualified for not shaking hands it is
in the rules she eventually was we just
kept
Harlan calls Thursday a difficult but
important day so she was Guided by her
heart and that after a year and a half
of fighting a handshake with a Russian
athlete would have been wrong right now
they they kill people in my country also
they killed Sports you know in general
[Music]
now the refusal to shake hands has come
up in other sports the Ukrainian tennis
player lost the match at this year's
French Open to a Russian player and was
booed by the crowd For What was seen as
unsportsmanlike I don't know I want to
see people react to it in 10 years when
the war is over I think this they will
not feel really nice about what they did
after her disqualification there was
support for Harlan the Ukrainian foreign
minister says she showed dignity while
NHL Hall of Famer Dominic kashuk says
she was put in an unfair position he's
calling on International Sports
federations and the international
Olympic Committee to ban Russian and
belarussian athletes
Ukrainian officials called for the
disqualification to be overturned if it
stood Harlan wouldn't be eligible to
compete at Team events in the world
championships and it would have
seriously hurt her chances to qualify
for next year's Olympics neither are
going to be a problem
suspension at the worlds has been lifted
she can compete and the head of the ioc
a former fencer himself went even
further Thomas Bach wrote to Harlan
Friday saying even if she doesn't have
enough qualification points they will
reserve a spot for her at the Paris
Olympics
Mike Armstrong Global News
and that is global national for this
Friday night I'm Nita Garcia tonight's
your Canada is the community of Bergen
Alberta about an hour Northwest of
Calgary we love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks so much for
watching and hope to see you here again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
thank you